das sind globuli arzneimittel steht auf
dem etikett aber ist es am ende
vielleicht nichts als zucker wer kennt
es nicht
es ist weihnachten die ganze familie
sitzt zusammen mit ihm läuft die nase
onkel günther hustet und dann zack tante
renate also ich nehme immer globuli
sobald es im hals kratzt und dann bricht
die erkältung gar nicht erst aus und
zack streitet die ganze familie
die einen sagen die kleinen kügelchen
die wirken wirklich wunde und die
anderen sagen ach hört mir damit auf das
ist doch nur quacksalberei aber wer hat
recht
das weiß kim bum becker er hat unsere
aktuelle titelgeschichte geschrieben und
den gehe ich jetzt mal besuchen
[Musik]
auch bei leichten erkältungen oder
schweren erkrankungen viele menschen in
deutschland erhoffen sich so einiges von
der wirkung der kleinen kügelchen
doch wissenschaftler sind sich einig
globuli wirken nicht über den
placebo-effekt hinaus dennoch geben die
deutschen viel geld für die zucker
kugeln aus über 600 millionen pro jahr
davon zahlen die gesetzlichen
krankenkassen freiwillig alleine 20
millionen völlig indiskutabel sagen
kritiker doch der
bundesgesundheitsminister widerspricht
wenn die menschen daran glauben warum
sollen die kassen ist dann nicht
bezahlen wenn sie es genau wissen wollen
lesen sie unser aktuelles heft dann sind
sie für die nächste diskussion mit der
verwandtschaft gewappnet und für die
nächste erkältung